depuis plusieurs semaines un membre de
l'équipe
déguisé en taupe s'amuse à faire des
crasses à ses petits camarades
la liste des victimes ne cesse de
s'allonger et pour le moment nous sommes
au stade 2 pour le moment personne n'a
réussi à démasquer le coupable c'est
pourquoi ce soir je vais avoir besoin de
vous pour cette enquête en direct pour
savoir comment pourquoi
mais surtout des quais poursuit les
chroniqueurs chaque jour à chaque
instant au bureau jusqu'à leur domicile
on joue tout de suite
akela tôt
[Musique]
vous êtes lavotour de cette table mais
nos fenêtres de potentielles victimes
mais aussi de potentiels coupables
pour ma part je suis blanc comme neige
comme d'hab élevé donc revêtir et
d'ailleurs j'ai déjà revêtu la tenue
d'un spectacle est très propre qui vous
sierre chez vous rejouez également vous
menez votre propre enquête
il y aura des indices il y aura de tout
en plus de ça ça vous permettra de
gagner un hoverboard ça on pourrait
déménager avec anne hidalgo
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
merci alors un vélo électrique ou encore
une trottinette électrique grâce à une
bonne urban ride moyen de transport qui
ne sont pas pour des blitz rendez vous
sur twitter
regardez ce qui s'est passé le mercredi
26 février aux alentours de 9 heures 03
qu'on est en train de faire actuellement
c'est inédit à la télévision une enquête
en direct avec les téléspectateurs
mercredi 26 9h03 quelqu'un est attaqué
regardez
[Musique]
à
[ __ ]
ce avec sa foot les mecs là encore on
nous attend on va les [ __ ] des mecs
mais je veux mourir vous allez voir dans
ses poches au palace à de la poudre se
répand le temps
[Musique]
mais bon hein
c'était mercredi 28 février aux
alentours de 9 heures 03 bien sûr si
j'avais été dans le quartier j'aurais
passé les bracelets malheureusement
j'étais pas là en tant qu'ancien delà
des erp et de la bac et de la méhari
je pose la question est mon
[Musique]
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez envie de
porter plainte c'est je pense que je
vais déposer une main courante
est-ce que vous avez une idée sur la
personne qui a pu vous faire ça pour
pour moi pas parce que je les ai vus
partir en courant en fait et quand il
court il a fait deux petits sauts de
cabri et deux petits sauts pour moi
c'est benjamin castaldi c'est vrai bric
castaldi fait souhaitiez vous le
mercredi 26 février c'est très facile à
9 ans j'étais au tennis comme tous les
comme tous les mercredis où tous les
mercredis castaldi j'ai les images vous
étiez bien au tennis ou peut-être pas
voici mesdames vous étiez vous à 9
heures le 26 février j'étais chez le
dentiste
chez le dentiste tout à fait comment
s'appelle le dentiste dr abitbol ce
qu'elle embrasse original nocture
abitbol c'est bien probable à la fois
non plus âgés l'apra jean-michel l'été
ou de tomber
audard mais oui alors je vous avez
quelqu'un qui peut qu a testé avec mon
chien edgar vous étiez où les novelli
ben moi je tenais justement à manger un
moyen pas perdre l'inspecteur gilles
verdez en donner un cours de journalisme
sportif à créteil à 9h à 12 d'isabelle
morini-bosc moi forcément j'étais rtl je
prends même qu'à 9 heures je suis allé
faire pipi
je me souviens d'avoir regardé l'horloge
fait les pieds à toutes les heures
montiel le point sur l'année pour i re
hannover moi j'ai enregistré christophe
willem sur rfm la tortue oui la tortue
ça passera d'ailleurs ça passera samedi
matin survie cost j'ai une province a
dit que j'étais à la radio regarder
c'est la meilleure sendra parce que
jamais au tennis j'ai pas vu de pendulo
com - les chéris bien après avoir
entendu aux alibis
[Musique]
je vous le dis je crois savoir déjà qui
est le coupable examen mais tous les
inspecteurs ont un binôme starsky à
swatch qui n'a d'eric assoit son mari
charles comme ce soit sonne et moi j'ai
mon boubou bobos donnez-moi lundi ce
numéro un
[Applaudissements]
le garder encore un bonheur de
travailler avec nous et on bobo
[Rires]
allez hop
j'avais mon collier en cellule d'accord
rocé jean michel maire c'est sûr je
prends ça glisse et vous jouez avec nous
la taupe a déjà travaillé sur une autre
chaîne à travailler donc pas jean-michel
ouais donc castaldi vous êtes encore
fait encore partie des coupables benhaim
également le jean michel maire vous avez
déjà ce site hors ce store ces stars
c'est pas une chaîne tps star c'est pas
une chaîne non plus vous êtes je
travaille sur une autre chaîne hippique
je réfléchis non je crois pas qu'elle iv
novelli vous est donc innocente d'eau
qu'elle est limitée que commandant
caporal et les huit minutes parce
qu'elle n'a jamais travaillé dans une
autre chaîne bravo
bocrie seignosse notamment ses news vos
wii france 3 est tout ouïe bien sûr f1
vous bien sûr elle fait vous bah non
vraiment bien sûr que vous êtes
on peut être victime et coupable
bien entendu agatha christie le meurtre
de roger ackroyd culture vous est
exempté
monnard on a une deuxième victime de ces
attaques
regardez ce qui s'est passé le mercredi
26 février aux alentours de 15 heures 10
il prévient et d'autres gens les images
sont d'une rare violence
regarde
[Musique]
x
pratique fête de parer d'atours 2b 2c de
l'autre le fracas d'une coupure au pouce
à part ça on aurait aimé dire non quand
elles reviennent se méfie pas rien
ça joue
c'est pas avec le vengerait à gaza et
pas quel culot de base est sûre dans le
magnéto
jean michel mr tu es d'accord bobos et
c'est un montage
je crois que c'est lui dans la taupe
elle est capable de le faire il est bon
ton gars je suis pas sûr qu'on va
travailler
je pense qu'on va très vite mettre fin à
notre collaboration parce que j'étais en
bep et certaines voix comme j'aime pas
ça gueule je veux qu'il aille en prison
tout ça je comprends que tu veux que je
passe les menottes
bonjour madame la cause tous ces mets
qui bronche je vais faire le tour de
périph dans le panier à salade pour le
moment jean michel maire nous avait
accusé eric naulleau mais comme on sait
les absents ont toujours tort et cette
fois j'ai en ma possession une vidéo une
vidéo
d'eric naulleau à qui vous répond à vous
dit le bouffon pour légende a berné
c'est peut-être vous regardez c'est rené
sage pour vous dire que ça ne pouvait
pas être moi dans la taupe parce qu elle
leur dit j'étais occupé à travailler
dans mon bureau alors travailler c'est
un verbe dont jean michel mr ignore la
signification et croyez bien que j'en
suis désolé car j'aurais adoré en mettre
plein la gueule à jean michel maire jean
michel mr et j'ai d'ailleurs un message
personnel pour lui sachent mon cher jean
michel que s'il devait y avoir une
attaque dans le futur elle se ferait une
attaque de ma part elle se ferait sans
masque sans costume et en face moi je ne
pratique pas le coup en douce qu'on ne
pas dire autre chose
le coup par derrière c'est ta spécialité
mais ça ne sera jamais jamais la mienne
voilà je t'embrasse amenez moi le
deuxième indice aux vecteurs g deuxième
indice j'ai bien réputé après vous je
viens de dire mais dans le deuxième il
faut pas le seul à trouver d'accord
c'est vrai appareil à cannes a dit cela
bah oui c'est sûr là tu as travaillé
dans le canon
ces bons français
tout tombe vous voulez que je dise un
disque des stagiaires miralis avec elle
du haut plateau étant souple
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vais travailler à l'école n'aurait
pas été impoli sociaux la folie la
toupie ton couple font monter la
meilleure et sauver sa face à lens avec
moi a tourné la neige arrive à sentir le
tu veux te dire un truc on prenait pas
j'étais content de faire équipe avec toi
et plus ça va je me dis que c'est un
échec
[Rires]
je sais c'est qu'il y ait une enquête là
oui je jockette en même temps que je les
regarde chef c'est parce que il ya aussi
le comportement et oui rien tu vas
t'occuper le cas du concours car la
taupe est en couple donc ça peut être
encore castaldi est toujours en couple
toujours mais là il mesure quand michel
nom jean michel maire c'est la vie qui
donc ça n'est plus vous
y at-il au sens mais le savez merci chef
kevin et aurélie n'êtes pas en couple
exclu ce n'est pas vous on sait pas trop
dans la catégorie des en couple ans
membre en coupe ou en couple à
célibataire
ge est innocent montiel oui prenez vos
clients vont claquer vos clics la qualif
est en couple vous coupe est vraiment de
tout les fans raymond en coupe plus
également donc on a perdu kalivie
novelli et bernard montiel kelly elle
reste il reste encore six personnes
chefs
oui guérilla n'est pas en couple
maintenant après ce spectacle qu'un
commissaire
[Applaudissements]
l'emprunt garde à vue chef monsieur
c'est à quelle heure la tacc de monsieur
26 10 15h10 ce que je faisais passons à
toute épreuve
c'est à 15h 10 inspecteurs boubou
là j'ai pas passé le cap je suis une au
pied des français
gd il ya une dernière victime dans
l'atome est témoin de ces plaques
îlotiers je viens des îles
[Applaudissements]
b
il est bien et il allait bien je me
lance dans le rock en plus travaillé
avec les plus grands
fin mai 68 à partir de maintenant nous
avons ce n'est que l'erreur si tout se
passe bien rejoindre est derrière qu'est
ce que ça vous fait des éclaireurs
supporter bon il ya une dernière victime
de la taupe
alors pourrait rigoler au pgi bomb ou
auxiliaire boubou
mais l'heure est grave
chez les vrais cheveux oui regardez ce
qui s'est passé le jeudi 27 février aux
alentours de 15h30 2
georges il travaille ça va merci mais
c'est sa superbe chanter et j'aimerais
qu'on va s'installer petit micro et puis
après il ya littéralement à monter à
l'étagé bien
moi je suis à disposition j'étais dans
l'émission de valérie bénaïm ça me plaît
beaucoup aussi
tout me plaît en fait du bon travail
sous l'égide de syrie to play
franchement le peuple et isabelle maxime
j'appelle beaucoup maxime kelly on
s'entend bien heureux et je vais pas des
soirées avec eux parce que chacun à une
vie à c'est pas toujours évident mais
bon il ya une bonne relation entre
ma compagne photo cyril sentons très
bien
elle avait participé en pire retour aux
premiers amours
exactement et alors sans oublier les
amours de des pmp exactement on va
diffuser un message juste avant
l'interview vais regarder la caméra de
droite est juste dire salut c'est gilles
verdez sûr possible comme c'est parti
pour mon interview 3 2 1 au top
salut c'est gilles verdez si on doit s'y
promener c'est parti pour mon interview
aux 3 2 1
les [ __ ] les compute 1
[ __ ] c'est un petit en plus gilles
verdez on est encore sur les cheveux
apparemment
le direct a raison gilles verdez
est-ce que vous avez une idée sur
l'identité du coupable oui parce que la
taupe à une démarche altière un peu
féminine que ça veut dire tu sais pas je
suis devenu d'antan longtemps et je
crois que c'est un piège et que cette
démarche altière comme justement la
grimpe mal au dos fait que la taupe et
valérie benaïm valérie bénaïm terrible
d'accuser quelqu'un sans preuve
c'est terrible de papous chef
oui elle a un alibi c'est quoi elle
était chez le dentiste mais d'après les
tout premiers meurtres mais là j'avais
un alibi excuse moi tu suis un petit peu
l'anc est comme ça les attendait à la
deux molaires mercredi c'était celle de
droite et jeudi celle de gauche j'ai pas
envie que ce soit valérie bénaïm ont
fait qui peut vous dire où il était le
jaudy 27 février à 15h30 de castaldi moi
j'ai très facile c'était le jour de
l'anniversaire de rohr donc je vais
tendre lui acheter un cadeau cadeaux qui
m'a été recommandé par kelly beinheim ya
quelques années quelques moments de ces
que de la tdg que la tv commencent à 17
heures que j'ai servi à 17h47 arrive
très tôt ici j'ai passé avec vous mentez
alors vous vous arrivez dans également
vous vous êtes mousse c'est bon vous
vous étiez où moi je rentrais à athènes
après avoir déjeuné avec mon ancien
patron il votre robin leproux
j'aime beaucoup mais ça n'a jamais été
mon patron ouais donc déjà ou d'une
connerie j'ai un major de dgt a dit cela
m'a jamais à moitié nus jouent pas c'est
fini beau et chez le médecin chez
l'ordonance n'ont rien à [ __ ] de leurs
deux noms ça peut il faut s'équiper un
nom et des roches à 9 ckoi bernard
madoff docteur est 27 février
mais alors sept jours en février mais si
sébastien
si vous changez les mollahs mais oublie
pas des gens c'est une pointure la
meilleure équipe du monde côtoie bien
génial et rantanplan et on va pas faire
long feu sur cette enquête laisse toi
aller bras cassé la troisième a dit ça
me donnait donc si tu pouvais bouger ton
cul jean dû être pompier mois alors
annoncer tout pas asus trois bateaux qui
a déjà été le jockey de cyril de joker
leclerc
[Rires]
[Musique]
tu crois tu crois qu'ils m'ont aidé ça à
la tondeuse on dirait un verre du
premier groupe menace et le joker le
joker de cyril gilles verdez vous êtes
innocent isabelle morini-bosc elle est
innocente
sophie qods est innocente vraiment tu es
innocent rina il reste donc deux
et ouais deux à pouvoir être les
coupables ce que vous nous confiez vous
plaît montrez-moi les deux visages barre
et gilles verdez barre et raymond c'est
au castaldi ou valérie tu va mener
l'interrogatoire avec moi pis si moi je
calcule le pouls
[Musique]
la question qu'on fasse une autre
enquête ans sans avoir résolu cette
affaire en prendre à chacun son char
castaldi fait partie des deux présumés
coupables
regardez valérie benaïm excuse-moi
macgyver la 200e dans les yeux un une
application et les pressions pour
quelles raisons vous n'auriez pas pu
être là tôt je suis trop bon camarade et
vous ne savez je suis trop gentil
je suis un homme qui n'a pas de vis
contrairement à mener est ce que tu as à
dire n'est pas un homme ça s'il attaque
gratuite envers un bétail mais je pense
que c'est lui mais c'est pas les
hurlements prison déjà que la cellule
est petit avec ses yeux il avait encore
petit mais faut le dire le dites le moi
dans les yeux enfin ouvrez vos yeux
d'être innocent je suis innocent mais
qu'est ce que ça veut dire que ces
innocents c'est pas moi l'idée n'est pas
coupable
[Rires]
astaldi valérie bénard ne pourriez pas
être le coupable à tout parce que ce
n'est pas dans mes manière d'attaquer
par derrière mes petits camarades
par ailleurs je n'aime pas tacher les
vêtements parce que j'aime la mode
donc je ne pourrais pas être honnête est
ce que vous avez déjà monté une fois
dans votre vie publique
ça m'est arrivé et pour des bonnes
raisons toujours pour les briques
installe dit mon tir oui très souvent
très souvent chef j'ai un truc qui peut
jouer en faveur de médailles mais c'est
quoi
elle a des problèmes de dos elle doit
pas sauté dans la rue absolument
ils s'allument merci mon dos va mieux
benjamin des problèmes de genoux mois et
demi deux éclopés agrégé au tennis dans
les deux si on plaçait au pc op on est
pas là pour mener une enquête
j'ai déjà assez bon second je vous
laisse une dernière chance à tous les
deux d'avouer votre crime car à l'heure
qu'il est
je sais que j'adore quand vous faites
s'achève la dernière fois tu le verras
attendez vous le savez pas ce que vous
avez une intime conviction ou es ce que
vous avez des preuves alors il ya
l'inspecteur baba cyril oui chef
ah bon tu crois pas que sur 30 dire un
truc important à pagesjaunes est le plus
important c'est quoi sur twitter les
gens ont voté crise
qu'est ce qu'ils disent à temps dans
l'écran est ce que c'est mais là il y
écrit on rame a sauvé line on s'en va
donc c'est benjamin pour les gens ou
témoin bien aujourd'hui et à 21h37 je
suis en mesure de vous dire que j'adore
ça
et celui qui a commis toutes les
infractions et délits
ces crimes délits début infractions
fraction échauffourées vous a permis de
la chaîne j'ai une seule chose à vous
dire on a les images pris deux minutes
richesse qui n'arrive à toi on a des
images là pour moi je vois des images
le coupable c'est en mesure de dire
qu'elle n'est pas arrivée pas tibet pas
et pour moi je vous le dis je ne sais
pas il va pas mais après mon enquête je
crois savoir
que le coupable la musique la musique
ses enfants
regardons les images si je me suis
trompé
[Musique]
malin visait à a
attendez 11 raconté afin de nous
ah ah
[Musique]
[Rires]
les bobos we call et moi sans cellule de
dégrisement surpassé par son bas de chez
moi dit je ferais des photos je suis
venu il a retiré sa la juge encore l
enquête rondement menée
[Rires]